what's going on everybody and welcome to
an update to the python self-driving car
and really plays GTA series in this
video I'm going to be talking about some
of the changes that have been made
recently and what's coming for the
future so first of all some of the
updates that we've made basically since
the last video I think I had 0.03 in the
last video 0.04 was just more waypoints
to 0.03 just to see if that would
continue on and then 0.05 was the
implementation of Xbox 360 controller
emulation so basically what happened
there is I used V joy to emulate just a
simple joystick in Python and then I
used a a program called like X 360 C II
which could take your simple joystick so
if you bought like just a cheap joystick
and you wanted to use it with something
that required an Xbox 360 controller you
could so that's you can basically map
pretty much anything to an Xbox 360
controller so with those two things with
VJ plus X 360 C II is able to emulate
next box 360 controller with Python so
that's what I did with 0.05 so basically
the way that works is the output of the
neural network is just key presses right
it was either WASD or combinations like
W a or W D or si and SD and so on so
take those take that output but the
output was never totally binary right it
was almost like it was like a percentage
it would be like 60 percent forward 10%
left 0% right 5% slowed down and so on
down the whole list of key presses that
were possible so what I do is I take
that output and then map that to the
controller so let's say the turn is 50%
left 10% right well take 50% - that 10%
right that's 40% left so let's take a
40% left turn so set that joy 40% over
that's basically hit there's there's
actually an algorithm
we used to pick the right values but
pretty much that
so that was version 0.05 and actually
that made some some pretty significant
improvements let me make sure the sound
is muted here and what I'll do I might
wind up being too loud but I pretty sure
this is zero zero five yeah zero point
zero five here so what it can do is
actually make much more fine-tuned
motion like whereas before it would if
it said okay the the largest out you
know the largest or basically what is
the output node is that happened to be a
left or right and it would be full left
full right whereas here what you can see
happening is it's got you know some
throttles happening some turn is
happening but it's so much more subtle
it can do a full turn
if the output layer is really like you
know go all out but for a more fine tune
required turning it can now actually do
that whereas you know before it could
weave but it was very violent weaving
whereas what you just saw there was very
subtle to get it through what it needed
to get through and then this will be
another example of just fine-tuned
steering I'm not sure this is weaving I
think this is just actually taking turns
right especially this term up here was
always really really difficult still
kind of difficult obviously you just
took a shortcut there he's kind of
cheating but a lot of it to just
correcting from terms and stuff like
that like you just couldn't do also
going in between two vehicles was always
really really hard for it cuz it can
never get perfect because it again would
always press a full on key which was
much more violent and I think this is
just driving in the hills basically and
these are just examples again as always
you can go to the stream watch it 24/7
because it doesn't drive this perfectly
all the time spoil alert but normally
just especially in the hills the hills
always gave it a really hard time just
because there's always stuff to get
stuck on but again as you can see he's
able just much more finely tuned
steering its everything's just much more
smooth with the Xbox 360 controller
emulation
like I said smooth look at them I'm
taking this position anyway okay so
there's that let's see oh and this also
you know one other thing that comes in
is being able to control a throttle so
for example if here's a real tight turn
and hard to tell but he actually pulls
back on the throttle significantly there
normally he would have just smashed into
that building like the older model every
time it came through this area would fit
right in there where this one actually
can control the throttle right it's not
actually a hundred either a hundred
percent full throttle or not just like
the turns it can be very granular so
that has helped significantly and then
here's some more examples I guess or
this is one with I guess throttle and I
don't know if it's going to turn or wet
here it's been a while since I posted
this one just barely made that exit yeah
normally like if he hadn't slowed down
for those turns normally it would have
just blasted into that wall
same thing there he just slowed down
quite a bit
okay so then 0.06 is the introduction of
a speedometer so actually 0.05 had two
million labeled frames and it drove
really well arguably I'd say 0.05
actually drove better than possibly 0.06
I think it's just because it had a lot
more data but with 0.06 started getting
curious about adding the speedometer so
I went ahead and added a speedometer I
can't remember I think in the recordings
these are like the sound is really loud
so if it's hard to hear me I apologize
anyway so with the the speedometer it
seems like at least to me it does appear
that it at least starts is starting to
understand how fast it's going it seems
to slow down from a high rate of speed
much better than it did before
and everything seems to be a lot more
smooth now we really want to you know
visualize the actual layers to be a
hundred percent certain that it's
actually seeing the speedometer I was
mostly just kind of toying with it just
to see like does this work at all like
is there any hope for a speedometer
being useful but it does seem to me that
it is useful now the problem is with
visualizing the layers like with like
something like deep dream the only way I
know how to do it is with raw tensorflow
not with TF learn because you have to
get like the actual like the graph file
and through TF learning do get a graph
file but it's not like the same format
and it's just it's just a but simply
above my head for how do we get what we
want for the deep dream so you know how
to make D dream with TF learn let me
know anyway um I see some of the issues
I don't know if he's actually going to
run directly into something here or what
oh no this is oh the tunnels so one of
the main issues here is since we're
using waypoints like waypoints came from
0.03 a lot when he enters a tunnel it's
just kind of a feature of GTA to
simulate the loss of GPS so so the
waypoint disappears
okay so then he's got to navigate the
tunnel so as you can see that case he
actually made the tunnel op many times
he'll go through that exact same tunnel
and he just loses his stuff because he
just doesn't know what to do without
that lovely Purple Line oh yeah and then
we gave him a ramp buggy this is just
interesting so one of the problems still
is that he just Rams right into other
vehicles again I think it's just because
he's got so much of a focus on
on that mini-map basically in that
purple line so he still runs into
vehicles in this case it's not a big
deal because he's driving the ramp buggy
so he just kind of goes right but anyway
that's that so onto the actual stream
now quite a few changes that happened to
the stream as you can see we actually
have a motorcycle working now it works
okay in third-person you definitely
don't to watch it in first-person but I
think just because it's such a small
thing on screen that just doesn't seem
to bother too much if you drive like a
car and third-person though it just
constantly like trying to avoid itself
because it just sees the car whereas the
motorcycle he clearly just does not care
if there's a motorcycle so so anyway
some of the other things that we've
added or as you can kind of see yeah you
can see the chat is we've added some
commands so the boost command just gives
them like a boost of speed just really
short term just in case you stuck or
whatever you can give them a boost also
rockets shoots rockets I'm not sure if
anybody's going to do it so I'll just do
rockets times two and then it takes a
second so there's just like a stream
delay by a twitch so it's like something
like six and eight seconds usually
hopefully we'll get somebody here direct
hit anyway so does a few chat
interactions there you can think the mod
Daniel for that one you can also do
stuck to get him to teleport back to the
road if he happens to get stuck and you
don't want to wait for the actual
automated mod to teleport him back and
then hopefully in the future we'll have
some other internet you chat
interactions like turning on and off
police maybe changing weather and that
kind of stuff somebody got happy there
also you can change the car so as you
can see here the car changes available
someone's about to change it it should
change to ramp buggy here in a moment
again because of the stream delay
there's really nothing I can do about
that it's just it is what it is so now
he's driving a ramp buggy which is just
basically a giant ramp so if he does
happen to hit anything it doesn't really
matter it just goes flying
so anyway also if you if you like to you
can actually subscribe to the actual
story
looks like someone did it boost at some
point there if you have Amazon Prime you
can actually subscribe to the stream
completely for free you can subscribe to
one stream a month if you have Amazon
Prime and it's connected to your twitch
account so to me it's the same thing as
any other sub so it's like you know free
money so um so yeah there's that trying
to think if there's anything else you
know for coming changes for things that
I'd like to change in as far as the AI
is concerned oh nice so it's not just
stuff so when you step you get some
fireworks in game as well see if we can
get some sad nice anyway um so let me
meet this again I like I said I think
when it records sound records actually
from the desktop and it will come
through the microphone as well but I
think it's pretty loud if you let it
come through the desktop anyway some of
the changes that I'd like to make in the
future obviously I'm still working on
like memory and reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is actually
already done the problem is it's really
slow at learning so it would take
probably months to see like noticeable
changes with what I have going I'm sure
there are people smarter than me that
could make it happen much faster it's
just I can't figure it out so anyway
there's just so many variables in Grand
Theft Auto but basically the way I'm
doing it is as you can see he's
following waypoints and then we can take
the way that we can generate a score is
how long does it take him between two
exact waypoints so I have a list of like
30 total waypoints that's a lot of
combinations I could make that list much
smaller to get those combinations more
frequently but basically how much time
does it take in between those two
waypoints given that we don't use a
teleport in any way so it's just purely
just getting there not getting stuck and
stuff along the way and then we can use
that time to generate a score of how to
get there now there's so many variables
especially with changing vehicles the
only vehicle that's really truly unfair
is probably the ramp buggy other than
that maybe the motorcycles because
they're much skinnier than normal
but otherwise all the vehicles are
relatively equal I mean some of them are
much faster than others for example the
monster truck is kind of let's be
serious now so it's like I would throw
out that data but we can use that but
the bottom line is it's just very slow
to learn it's just a very complicated
task so there's that also I'd love to
add memories still working on memory
I've done it done recurrent layers on
this data it just didn't perform any
better than the pure convolutional
neural network and yet it costs like 10
times in processing and maybe that's why
I didn't do any better right because it
had less frames per second that it could
go through so it's reaction time was
just simply worse and I've already seen
that if I can improve this frame rate
like right now it reads and understands
at about 60 to 90 frames a second maybe
on this machine actually more like 6070
but for some reason on my main computer
which is actually on lesser Hardware if
this machine process is about 80 to 90
frames per second and this in running
Charles on this machine he does way
better so I'd love to eat out more
frames per second so anyway maybe that's
all it was with the recurrent layers and
if we could get 80 to 90 frames a second
with the recurrent layers then it would
be just like so much more better but I
really don't know at this stage so
there's that also um like a non you know
self driving change I'd like to make is
one of the things that's really
interested me about this project is from
the very beginning when I put it up on a
stream was that people were being
entertained by an AI we have you know
well initially we had thousands of
computers because of all the news that
it got but lately it probably like the
last month we've had a consistent summer
between 20 and 60 viewers at any given
time just simply watching an AI play a
game that's pretty interesting to me
so anyway one of the things I'd like to
also do is get a chatbot going for
Charles so bring Charles in as a chatbot
and interact with people in the actual
chat and try to make a full-on
actual streamer and all that at least
for the initial stuff I probably will
have some how to create a chat bot with
deep learning I'm not sure I'll cover
the whole project but definitely
something out there for that if I do get
around to doing that there's anything
else that I wanted to cover in this one
I think that's that's basically it oh
the other thing the other thing besides
doing reinforcement learning and
possibly memory I also chose grant to
follow because there's other tasks that
you can do so obviously you could I
suppose do missions and stuff but I
don't really think I'm going to go that
route I don't even know how I would
around while we're doing is driving I
would really like to get Charles out of
the car as well so actually I would like
to be able to have him both drive and
not drive I'd like him to actually be
able to commit GTA but alright that
would be that's basically the epitome of
Grand Theft Auto right you got to be
able to steal cars so anyway so I might
add that as well later on I still want
the driving to improve the driving is
actually better than I ever thought I
would be at this point but it definitely
has a lot of room for improvement so but
I'd also like Charles to be able to do
other things besides just drive a car I
think that'd be make for more
interesting stream as well anyway a lot
of information there hopefully I'm not
leaving anything out a lot of changes
have happened also just to give credit
where it's due the chat mod daniel i'm
not going to pronounce his last name
this guy is responsible for all of the
twitch interactions so shooting rockets
changing cars the fireworks when you
subscribe and donate and all that kind
of stuff the ability to drive a ramp
buggy because by default the ramp buggy
actually only has a cockpit view it
doesn't have a hood view so he actually
customized that the hood view also the
fact that we can drive third person
motorcycles such as auto switches third
person all that stuff is thanks to him
so if you're enjoying those those
changes make sure you
you highlight them and say thanks in the
in the chat anyway that's all for now if
you want to check out the stream it's
twitch TV slash semtex again you can
subscribe totally for free if you have
Amazon Prime you can also donate on the
stream or go to the patreon page or
whatever this is running 24/7 so come
check us out otherwise questions
comments below see you in another video